all right so the Marvels is out and
apparently you all really like hearing
me talk about the Marvel so here we are
the Marvel spoiler talk and that is a
fair spoiler warning for you if you
haven't seen the Marvels and you intend
on seeing the Marvels you might not want
to watch this video yet if you haven't
seen the Marvels and you have no
intention of watching the Marvels
somehow you still stumbled on this video
uh welcome hang out for a few minutes
but as is the case with all my spoiler
talk videos this is not going to be a
play byplay I'm not going to go through
the script Page by Page and talk about
every little Det detail she's going to
talk about some things that stood out to
me but I couldn't talk about my
spoiler-free review because well
spoilers all right introductions done
disclaimer complete let's talk so the
plot of the baddy whose name I
completely forget and I'm not going to
grab my phone to Google Dollar Store
Ronin which I feel I have to clarify
that I was telling a friend about it and
he was like well I mean Ronin wasn't a
bad villain I'm like okay let me clarify
this is not just Ronin again Dollar
Store Ronin all of the hammer none of
the anything else but the main
motivation behind Dollar Store Ronin
doing baddy things is her world is dying
you see in the movie that took place
before the marbles that we never saw and
doesn't exist but really does feel like
there is a movie that's supposed to
exist somewhere Captain Marvel took out
this master control program from Tron
but in the real world in the MCU that
was governing and managing this world
and now the world's just more [__]
which is a weird conversation that I've
noticed in a lot of movies lately tin
foil hat moment have you noticed that
conversation about AI has shifted as
we've used AI more in our World it used
to be Metal Gear Solid 4 AI is bad
Terminator AI is bad you know like ai's
always been bad but now the Creator not
all AI is bad I mean I like the Creator
and all but that was noticeable and now
in the Marvels is she takes out this big
AI machine and the conversation is
everything got worse after you did that
interesting anyhow now that she did that
their son is
dying I guess did I miss that too in my
spoiler free review I addressed that it
feels kind of intermittent the way
they'll use their power and sometimes
they'll swap with each other and
sometimes not and someone in the comment
section I saw was like it addressed that
they have to use powers at the same time
which I missed did I miss something here
too I won't lie more than a few times in
here I I did find myself zoning out to
be fair there was a planet in which
people had to sing to talk and using cat
vacuums to gather up people I'll get
there in a second anyhow I don't see the
correlation between AI gone and now
everything's worse and by the way Sun's
dying and the sun dying is your fault
maybe I'm just getting old and my
attention to detail is in fact waiting
or maybe movies are getting lazy and not
concisely illustrating what is linked to
what when it comes to the plot maybe my
own bias makes me want to say it is the
latter but the point is bad's like okay
I'm going to make jump points to other
worlds and steal their water steal their
air steal their Sun that'll leave them
in a bad place funny thing I noticed
about her world in which her son is
dying everything was really dark which
you know I get not because the sun's
dying but because that hides bad CGI now
the sun dying is a weird thing when a
Sun dies doesn't it get hotter I mean
it's basically in that respect the plot
of of the movie Sunshine but with
superheroes in sunshine we just kind of
sit back and buy it but at least in
sunshine on Earth there was a lot of
snow and it looked cold as I understand
it as our sun dies it's going to get
hotter so I think that would have been
more interesting if their sun is getting
hotter and they're actually cooking to
death rather than it being dark all the
time I would say freezing but it wasn't
freezing it just seemed really dark not
really cold you know they're all outside
talking I don't see their breath I'm
like obviously it's not that cold but if
their sun was progressively getting
hotter that that would have put a clock
on it I think that'd be more interesting
not we're running out of Flashlight
batteries it should get fixed soon as
for the side quests I already told you
about one of the side quests of the
singing planet where everyone has to
sing to you and you have to sing to them
and that's how communication works I
heard after my upload that that's
actually the plot of an episode of
Transformers y cartoon from the80s which
I do own on DVD and I was like I should
watch it so I can compare and contrast
in my spoiler Talk video then I realized
you know I've been waterboarded with
that [__] plot mechanic in one movie
I don't need to see it again so I didn't
but it's interesting that it seemed like
a plot point from an episode from an '
80s cartoon and lo and behold it was the
other one's the cats all right you know
that cat that's not really a cat but it
has tentacles that come out of its mouth
and it eats people which I guess stay
alive they don't die on Nick Fury's
space base that cat has a lot of kittens
that also aren't cats that have
tentacles that come out and eat things
and at a point everything's going to
[__] up there they have to get everyone
off of this space base the only way to
do that is everyone just take a cat all
the heroes anyway take cats and they
just vacuum people up into the cats
which sounds like a pretty fun Luigi's
Mansion mod and in a video game well it
would be but this is an FCU film it just
came across as stupid say what you want
about this movie being made for lonely
cat ladies maybe you don't like those
jokes but this movie's leaning into it
see all the heroes vacuum up the crew
they get to Earth all the cats vomit the
people out and there you go you got
people safe on the ground all also a lot
of cats and kittens that are definitely
going to run and escape and breed does
it break the world yes do they give a
[__] no they they just thought it was
funny that's skip into the end of the
movie but while we're talking about side
quest here we are going back a little
bit well Valkyrie is in the movie she
makes a cameo how did she summon the
bifrost to make a cameo I have no
earthly idea but it happened and this
just annoys me Star Wars does this the
MCU does this the umbrella of Disney
does this where the energy is that of
early 9s sitcoms like in TGF you'd have
one character from one show Cameo and
another and they'd walk in all like hey
everybody sorry it took me a while to
get here all the cats were filled
up like who made the call of hey let's
recapture that energy in the biggest
cinematic franchises on Earth right now
sounds great and like I said in my
spoiler-free review this movie does have
a couple of good Concepts that it never
takes the time to flesh out one of them
is they're trying to save this community
community of Scrolls buildings are
falling down it's just it's a mess and
Kamala Khan's like we got to save him
and Captain Marvel's like we have to
save the ones we can that I thought was
a great line and a great moment this fan
girl comes face to face with her hero
she has these idealistic versions of
what a hero should be but the Grim
reality is Heroes Have to make those
calls of all right in order to save
these people we have we have to let
those people die otherwise if we try to
save them no one gets saved and it
happens once for a moment and then we
just move on come on Malon being a fan
girl and having to come face to face
with the Grim reality of heroism I think
would have been a great movie but AI
doesn't know about such Concepts no this
movie wasn't written by AI trust us fast
forwarding pass some CGI battles and
already talked about the cats all you
know sucking
people sucking up you know like
hoovering people like tentacle vacuum
tentacles doesn't make it better we're
moving on oh we get to the point of
Monica Rambo in a film that is basically
fan girl hangs out with two boring
ladies Monica Rambo is going to show us
exactly why she's here she's here so we
can get that juicy post credit scene
that's it if the baddy punches a hole in
the universe nay the Multiverse I was
like oh yeah Multiverse I forgot that's
that's always the thing and in order to
fix it she needs to go to the other side
of this hole in SpaceTime and close it
up cuz that's that's her power what is
her power she says she sees all
spectrums of light also she can go
through things also she can patch a hole
in in SpaceTime the newest trailer just
that's all the end of the movie it shows
the Teran SpaceTime it shows Monica
Rambo going through it and sealing it
because this is the real trailer the
real sales pitch come and see the movie
so you can see what happens in the mid
credit scene that's what matters and
that newest trailer shows that they know
that but she goes through she's stuck on
the other side Captain Marvel's like
man oh yeah the Sun and she flies
through the sun reignites the Sun so
that problem's fixed so the post credit
scene once the movie ends and then
there's another scene has nothing to do
with the credits and that's when Kamala
Khan's waiting and Kate Bishop gets back
and she's like she basically does
exactly the Nick Fury thing she's
sitting in the shadows like you've
become part of a bigger world you just
don't know it yet though you very much
do because everyone I have pictures of
Captain Marvel on my wall everyone knows
who these aventures are like the scene
would have been perfect in a Deadpool
movie in the Marvels feels a little too
meta but again in a world where most of
the other people in this movie are just
asleep at the wheel coasting through
this script they know sucks Aman volani
is actually clock on to work so she
actually does have fun with the scene
and that's what sells it that's not
really the credit scene people are
talking about the mid credit scene is
what you want to talk about and it was
it's you already know what it is we live
in a world where we've been told the
X-Men are coming to the MCU very quickly
Monica Rambo was trapped in another
dimension and she's wounded what do you
think it's going to be or do you think
she's going to wake up right she wakes
up in a medical facility she's talking
to a variant of her mom and then someone
comes in who sounds like Kelsey Grammar
and it's Beast I like the fact they made
him look like '90s Beast you know he
looked like beast from the 9s animation
cuz that's that's Prime beast to me
that's the Beast that I know that said
man that was some CGI Beast someone
didn't want to just get in the chair and
do the makeup sitting in that makeup
chair for hours getting all that makeup
it sucks I can only imagine you know
what else sucks cartoon characters in a
live-action movie that's not supposed to
have cartoon characters I don't mean
cartoon throwback characters I mean
animated cartoon looking characters
because the CGI is just that then Monica
Rambo's variant mom stands up and she
has an outfit with a symbol and I was
like I don't know what that is but hey
CG Beast says the X-Men are coming baby
look in the end the Marvels is a
movie it's a movie that has a glimmer or
two of what could have been a good movie
if they' taken it a little further they
gone the distance with it as it stands
just looks like a movie that happened
things happen in the movie have a a
couple of fetch quests a couple of
Worlds it's a Frank and [__] of about
four different concepts of a comic book
movie that could have been stitched into
one you give it lightning and you can
say anything but it's alive cuz it's not
it feels unimaginative and dead as [__]
you know what else sucks in this movie
since I'm just kind of on a roll of
things that suck the costume the
costumes suck I'm mainly talking about
Captain Marvel and Monica Rambo's
costumes at first Captain Marvel's
outfit's legit it looks like Captain
Marvel's outfit and at a point her
outfit changes
and it's just worse it looks like that
Meme of when you order it online versus
when it arrives even the material of
that pattern that star pattern on her
chest it looks like cheap plastic action
figure gold also Monica Rambo's outfit
like what is her outfit last time I saw
her she had clothes that looked kind of
like a throwback to a superhero costume
but you know still clothes now they're
like she needs a superhero outfit let's
just give her like what is it why is it
I you're not about to go go for the
keyboard to type its comic book accurate
in the comment section are you cuz come
on the MCU is full of costumes that
merged the concepts of superhero costume
and practical uniform wearable clothing
this looks like she's about to fight
ivanu in 1995 and there we are done with
the spoiler Talk of the Marvels with no
Scotch so you don't have to my friends
so you don't have to first so the
Marvel's already asked you if you've
seen it and what did you think about it
so what do you think the MCU should do
cut back on the TV shows cut back on the
movies cut back on both whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see
[Music]
more